14 days later the shadow blacker than
any passing clouds swept over Harrenhal
Veigar had come at last and on her back
road 1i prince aemond he mocked the
demon for facing him alone you have
lived too long uncle and damen replied
him on that much we agree then the old
prince climbed stiffly onto the back of
his dragon carrick sees but neglected to
fasten the chains that secure rider to
Sun the Sun was close to setting when as
one the two dragons left into the sky
Damon took our axes up swiftly until
they disappeared into a bank of clouds
veigar older and slower ascended more
gradual up and up veigar sword searching
for currencies sudden as a fundament a
shrieking karoxa stove on vague are
locked together the dragon stumbled
toward the lake corrects his jaws closed
about vague arsenic but Vega raked open
cracks his belly and her teeth ripped
off a wing delay crushed up with
terrible speed then daemon Targaryen
court never fastened his writing chains
stood in his saddle he left from his
dragon to a man's and in his hand was
dark sister the Valyrian sword of
Aegon's sister Queen Visenya as Amon one
I looked up in terror Damon ripped off
his nephews helm and drove the sword
down into his one remaining I so hard
the point came out the back of the young
prince's throat half a heartbeat later
the Dragons struck the lake sending up a
gowk of water so high that it was said
to have been as tall as her and halls
great tower
the lake boiled with dragon blood and
then was still
hey youtubers is charlie so new game of
thrones footage is actually from the
season five DVD bonus features they did
like a full 20 minute episode based
based on this it's based on the princess
in the Queen or the blacks and the
Greens the story is called the dance of
the Dragons it's all about one of the
first Targaryen civil wars I'm going to
talk a little bit about some of the
people that were part of season four
notably Pedro Pascal so just careful for
spoilers if you're not caught up on the
show there is actually a new round of
the giveaway that's starting now to all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video just a twenty-dollar amazon gift
card the DVD doesn't actually come out
till March fifteenth so it's going to be
a while before we get the full episode
of this but I'll totally give away a
couple free copies whenever it comes but
as I said Pedro Pascal who narrates the
this little clip is just one of the cast
members that's actually part of the big
20 minute episode they also got Jack
Gleeson who played Joffrey Mark Addy who
played Robert Baratheon Harry Lloyd who
played Viserys Carrie ingram who played
Shireen Baratheon still really upset
about what happened to her in Michelle
Fairley who played Catelyn Stark all
those people are part of the 20 minute
version of this so i highly recommend
you buy the season five DVD the
important stuff though if you don't know
anything about the dance of the Dragons
it was one of the first one of the early
Targaryen civil wars it happened before
the Blackfyre rebellion the reason it's
called the dance of the Dragons is
because it happened during a time when
there were many dragons so both sides
fought on dragonback it was his really
you know spectacular aerial battles
involving lots of dragons lots of people
died but the reason it started is
because King veceras the first is his
first wife died he had three children
only one survived to adulthood and she
was groomed to succeed him but then he
remarried and had a bunch of other
children with the second wife so you can
kind of see where I'm headed with this a
lot of people swore fealty to the
princess from his first marriage a lot
of other people swore fealty to the new
queen and her son's the reason both
sides of the war are called the blacks
or the Greens is because they had this
big tournament before things went crazy
and Queen Alison the new wife wore green
and Princess ranier ax the the daughter
from the first marriage wore black so
you get the idea for the different
colors but things really didn't heat up
until King veceras died then it was like
you know who is going to succeed him
half the kingdom swore fealty to the
princess the other half swore fealty to
the new queen there were a whole bunch
of different engagements there were
whole bunch of really big figures
involved now the clip that Pedro Pascal
here is narrating is called the battle
of gods I that was the particular
engagement Prince Damon with cracks
easier challenge Prince Ayman to a duel
waited 13 days at Harrenhal then as you
can see a Monroe tin on Veigar they
battled in the sky but it was meant to
be a big blow from the blacks to the
greens as well as you know personal few
that had gone on between cousins Prince
Damon who wielded dark sister in it you
know driving it through a man's face he
rode for the blacks that's princess
ranier ax Prince Ayman road for the
Greens the the second wife Queen Allison
Hightower obviously details how they
both fall into the lake you know cause
this big spire of water to rise up in
the air taint the water red with dragons
blood but they didn't recover Prince
amons body with dark sister still drove
through his eye till years later he was
the one that was still chained to his
dragon they claimed that they never
found Damon's body he was the one who
wielded dark sister and jumped from
dragging a dragon a lot of people think
that he know he went off to live the
rest of his life with his lover most
people think the logical conclusion is
is that the fish just ate his body and
the interesting thing about the dance of
the Dragons is the way that it ended
what ended up happening is is that it
seemed like the Greens won the son of
Queen Allison Aegon the second ended up
taking the throne that's the green so
you could say the Greens one but then
when he died Aegon the third was named
King and he was the son of princess
renea the other side of the war the
blacks so I guess you could say
ultimately the blacks ended up winning
but really just a whole bunch of people
ended up dying and it became this big
debacle you can kind of see what a
problem it becomes when there are a lot
of Targaryen heirs that's one of the
reasons why Maester Aemon ceded the
throne to his younger brother when he
was selected to become the next king
it's just like way too many brothers I
don't want to cause another Civil War
like the dance of the Dragons so I'm
gonna go take the black so like I said
you'll be able to buy the DVD March
fifteenth get like the full 20 minute
episode is probably just going to be an
expanded dance of the Dragons they'll
probably tell the whole story I mean
it'll be like an abridged version
because there's really like two
different short stories that Martin
wrote about it so they could turn it
into a whole series if they wanted to
but the problem in doing that is that
you'd have to do a lot of dragons there
were a lot of dragon battles and its
really expensive to do the effects for
those I know it doesn't seem like it is
but it costs a ton of money that's why
you don't see Daenerys dragons in every
single episode
is one of the reasons I think that if
they're going to do a game of thrones
spinoff series that they'll do dunk and
egg just because it requires way less
dragons way less special effects so it'd
be a lot cheaper for them to do and it's
a lot closer to modern-day but you guys
let me know in the comments like if
there is a spin-off series that they're
going to do would you rather than do the
dance of the Dragons or something else
just just imagine something that doesn't
require a lot of CG congratulations to
last week's giveaway winner Marlo
Mitchell you and a twenty dollar amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back into my channel so I get
your contact info what's going to happen
next is I'm going to be doing a Star
Wars Episode 7 Q&A video I've got a
couple other Easter Egg videos this week
I'm going to be doing some character
videos a lot of Star Wars happening this
week for obvious reasons hopefully you
guys have seen it if you haven't be sure
to go see it it is amazing there are a
whole bunch of Game of Thrones actors
that ended up being in episode 7 you can
click here turn all about the cameos in
the movie and you can click here to
learn all about Valyrian weapons thank
you so much for watching everybody
what's that 5 i'll see you guys tonight
you